This morning, I read an interesting story about a two-year-old Indian girl...
...born with four arms, four legs, and extra internal organs.
And guess what?
Doctors removed her extra limbs successfully!
What a relief.
And she will go back to her rural village...
...where she had been revered by some...
...as an incarnation of the four-armed Hindu goddess she was named after.
Speaking of incarnation, do you believe in rebirth Alex?
Have you thought about you being reborn as someone or something else?
Although I don't believe in an afterlife,...
...if I had the chance to be transmigrated,...
...I'd want to be reborn as a female from a high-class family...
...with a high-profile figure in my family, like a president.
In that case, I would be super rich.
Also, I'd want my parents to be from totally different countries or cultures...
...like a mom from an Asian country and a dad from the west...
...so I can have two perfect mother tongues.
I don't want to look like a total Asian or Caucasian.
What about you Mi-na?
I'd want to be reborn as a Korean again.
Hopefully, at that time,...
...the country will be one of the most powerful nations in the world.
I want my parents to be Korean too.